amazon just acquired roomba
for 1.7 billion dollars well i think
that's pretty [ __ ] crazy to begin
with this robotic vacuum company that
has just been made fun of for like a
decade just sold for 1.7 billion
yeah this is such a skymall product the
fact that it act people actually use and
buy roombas yeah like do you have one no
i don't have one yeah i'm not a funny
i'm not an idiot i've never owned one of
those wait you didn't buy the 300 robot
that paints your cat [ __ ] all over the
ground
you don't want to buy that
you didn't want to hire this [ __ ]
unemployed loser to hang out in your
house and just make art with animal
feces
does it actually do that have you ever
seen like a video yes no way actually a
dog or something will [ __ ] um
funny and the roomba will just pick it
up like a degenerate and just start
making art all over the ground i've seen
tick tocks people coming home being like
my roomba some red [ __ ] all over my
apartment and they're just
filming
that's so funny
what's that smell oh
god
oh look at the bottom of the yeah oh
it's all cotton yeah that's awesome yeah
1.7 billion dollars here folks yeah one
point literally if you have a stupid
product idea just do it yeah just make
it you too can have an art student
living in your home rent free just
bumping into [ __ ] freeloading and making
art with that's the best part is that
they don't even like really work no like
what is it it goes around and it bumps
in your couch like 50 times yeah dude
look at this
oh my god this is how your animals get
back at you
just crawl up on your roomba and [ __ ]
fertilize your living room
[ __ ] off of it yeah gotta love this all
right so the dog leaves one just so
pudding signature he's gonna eat it just
to make sure it is gonna take a whiff
you ever do this after you [ __ ] turn
around and just stick your nose in the
toilet yeah give it a big way yeah make
sure it's mine
all right so that was at 8 23 am 114. so
it's been sitting there for a decent
chunk of time dude it's like
intentionally smearing it yeah another
why is it going back and forth the room
is getting back too you're gonna leave
me off the charger
maybe you should charge me more maybe
i'll get around the house a little bit
better
yeah maybe if you didn't talk about how
bad of a job i did all the time yeah
1.7 billion billion
those [ __ ] had the last laugh i'm
sure the story is like two bald guys
that like really care about science and
[ __ ] or they don't i just pictured two
guys high as hell looking at a rc car
tape your broom to that totally and
they're just laughing like just [ __ ]
just around their kitchen like yo it's
actually working yeah yo what if we sold
this 15 years later billionaires yeah
well
honey when it comes time to eat the rich
they got something else on the menu
we just sold for 1.7 bill
nice that's a great quote thanks dude
it's time to eat the rich come and see
me cause daddy is loaded else is on the
menu roomba ceo just got added to the
appetizer menu of eat the rich
would you be concerned that amazon knows
what the inside of your house looks like
everyone's scared that the roomba now is
gonna take a map of your house and then
amazon's gonna have a map of your house
and they're not amazon already knows
everything you buy it employs your
entertainment and it hears you it hears
you it sits on your front alexa i mean
yeah yeah yep it's too late they even do
with that info it's too late restaurants
have [ __ ] apps that track what you
order it's over that's what i'm saying
like why are people concerned about that
i mean it's personal data i get it we
should be concerned with what's
happening with our data i i'm fully on
board with that i'm just wondering like
that seems to be the main gripe is that
people are like oh they're gonna know
what the inside of my house looks like
now they will
so what yeah i mean i'm honestly curious
i don't want them to know where my couch
is that data gets hacked people now have
floor maps to your home yeah that's true
actually yeah like windows and
doors and i but it's not gonna map [ __ ]
like that does the roomba have a camera
on it i'm assuming let's google that i i
just thought it was like an ant like it
just had like some feelers well here
it's equally ambitious with the aim to
get a better understanding of a home
through ai and smart features and then
extend to other areas of the smart home
interesting yeah so the roomba learns
where the most mess is
honey why does the roomba keep trying to
vacuum the corner of your room uh i
don't know
i don't know oh honey it's so what's
going on over here did you spill
something it's crusty
the room would just start snitching on
you but yeah no it starts shining a
black light
i didn't know it what starts talking
yeah chemical composition of this aspect
come detected oh god the rumor just
rolls over it's just like
it just rolls like three like 180
this tastes like semen
just is this that [ __ ] robot from
lost in space yeah annoyingly
intelligent hi mom daniel [ __ ] in the
corner of his room again
danger
danger come in the corner danger come in
the corner wait what is that okay with a
camera that can identify and avoid pet
droppings instead of smearing it all
over the floor the device will
gracefully avoid the poop and even snap
a picture and text it to your phone see
that
it's cool but again you don't need a
[ __ ] roommate can you imagine your
roomba being a roommate yeah
yeah
yeah man just chilling on the ground
again
i'm not [ __ ] touching it but i'm just
letting you know yeah listen i'm not
pissed
we've talked about this before get your
dog in order what the [ __ ] is your
roomba gonna tell you to clean some [ __ ]
up that is really funny yeah you do
something about it yeah you're the robot
no don't i [ __ ] pay you to clean i
can't i don't mess with poo man i'm not
equipped man